hi there this is steve kaufman uh to
talk about languages and today i want to
talk to you about why i enjoy learning
languages
remember if you enjoy this channel if
you you know please subscribe if you
like this video please give me a like
so i'm going to be rambling here a bit
but i want to think about why it is i
enjoy learning languages
because enjoying
language learning is a big part of
success people who don't enjoy learning
languages are less likely to be
successful you can't force yourself to
do something that that involves your
emotions involves a a commitment to
sort of imitating another language and
culture and
getting outside of the comfort of of
your language one that you're used to or
you're so
able to express yourself and you're
forcing yourself out of that and you
have to enjoy the process or you won't
do it so why do i enjoy it
so first of all i think it's when i am
learning languages when i'm engaged in
any activity whether it be reading or
listening or maybe i have a an online
discussion with a tutor
i really feel
that what i am doing is valuable
uh and it's valuable for a variety of
reasons first of all i actually enjoy it
i enjoy discovering a new language how a
new language works how they count in
turkish how they
all the different things that they do
that are different from
farsi or persian different from chinese
different from english so i enjoy
discovering that
uh i know that i'm going to say in
turkish
going to get to a point where i can
actually read things of interest
in turkish so i can
i'll be able to read about turkish
history ottoman empire whatever it might
be
you know ataturk
all of these things in turkish i'm
looking forward to that so there's a
sense of anticipation so i know that
that what i am doing
first of all is going to benefit me
in terms of
learning the language so i enjoy what
i'm doing i know that i'm going to get
through what i'm doing the ability to
speak and understand the language
and i know that i'm going to be able to
access so many things that i wasn't able
to access before so therefore the time
that i spend is valuable
so i focus on that all of the positive
things that come from
learning the language therefore it's a
valuable thing to do
i don't worry so much about what i'm
able to say and i think sometimes people
who are concerned about
how much they can say and how quickly
they can say it
they are more likely to get frustrated
because actually it's very difficult i
can have a lot of words that i have
learned that i understand passively
that i've i've read many times i've
heard many times and then i have a
conversation with my tutor and i can't
find those words i can't even find some
of the most basic words often
why or anything all of a sudden is blank
so if a major say
sense of achievement comes from being
able to say something in the language
then it's it's very easy to get
frustrated to me it's that sense of
discovery
the
looking forward to all the additional
things i can discover
then you know for example where my wife
and i were watching this very amusing
turkish soap opera baba john something
or other
and it parts of it take place in
istanbul parts of it take place in
ugroup i think the name is town where
i'll have all these
uh in cappadocia where they have these
rock formations
we're going to go to turkey
and i'm going to be able to speak
turkish when we go to turkey
make mistakes when i'm in turkey but i'm
going to have a level of access to this
culture in this language that i would
never have without having learned the
language
so all of this sort of fills me with a
sense of discovery and and i know i am
progressing even when i don't feel that
i'm progressing i know that i'm
progressing i don't judge my progress by
how well i did in my last conversation
with my tutor
i judge my my
i don't even worry about my progress i
know that i'm reading better than before
i know that for example my mini story is
for turkish and the same is true for
persian and arabic
when i started it was just noise i
couldn't figure out what they were
saying what words meant and how they fit
it together and now i would say
at least 50 of the 60 stories i
understand them perfectly so i have
achieved something even if i struggle to
use these words and even if i make
mistakes and i make the same mistakes
over and over again it's difficult to
nail the tenses in turkish and but i
know also that in time it'll get better
if i just you know continue doing what
i'm doing so it's enjoyable to me the
other thing about language learning is
for me
first of all i'm retired so there is no
limit
to how much i can improve in any
language or how many new languages i can
discover it's essentially limitless
so i my whole retirement is full
whatever else i have going if there's a
slow
moment i can go back to learning
languages and
learning languages the way i do
heavily reliant on
listening here
it makes household tasks
enjoyable cleaning up
uh cleaning up in the garage working out
there's so many such in the car i can
always listen
of course listening is not enough
uh listening is a big part of sort
of ingraining the phrases phrases and
words into your
into your brain in a way that you'll be
able to use them
but reading is also key in order to
expand your vocabulary so i do i do
combine both of them but the listing is
so easy to organize
and it makes the everyday tasks um
enjoyable i don't mind cleaning up i'm
going to listen to
whatever turkish and it's enjoyable
when i understand it so much better than
i used to understand it so those are my
sense
or call them milestones of achievement
so
i enjoy languages because of the
discovery i enjoy languages because i
know that it's an activity that is an
activity an exercise in discovery but
also it leads you to these other things
friends that i'll be able to make i'll
be able to have
dinner conversations in turkey when we
visit turkey so there's all of this
positive anticipation so
you know there are moments in life when
we have
uh pleasant evening with friends but
that's all you get it's that evening
then it's gone now you have the memory
maybe but but you know moments of
enjoyment can be fleeting
in life but with language learning it's
sort of like you get a triple punch you
get the the enjoyment of the activity at
least it is for me
you get the discovery of the language
and then you get all the things that
that's going to lead to so it's an
investment in future enjoyment
um
in a way that a wonderful meal and a
nice bottle of wine is is an investment
in the enjoyment of that evening and
perhaps the memory of it but you aren't
necessarily investing in
many many good things to come so that's
my view i
do enjoy learning languages um
i'm not tired of it if i get tired of
language a i move to language b
whatever i have put into a language
however little i have achieved in the
language
it's still
been a positive experience a positive
discovery and it's also something that i
can go back to
so
my greek and my romanian which are the
two sort of call them stunted languages
in my repertoire i have all my mini
stories if i start listening to them i
understand them all i can go back to
those
and
placed in a situation where i had to use
it i'd quickly be able to bring it back
to where it was so whatever i have put
into these languages same with my
three middle eastern languages now
arabic persian and turkish
focused now on turkish i'm slipping a
bit in persian and arabic but
occasionally i look at my assimil book
in those languages or i listen to a mini
story in the car and it all comes back
to me so nothing is lost
so there you have it that's why i enjoy
learning languages i would like to hear
from you why you enjoy learning
languages or why you don't enjoy
learning languages
okay thank you bye for now
you